you're not going up anymore well i got
everything planned you'll have covetous
you know you you got to take a vaccine
and then you've got to wait two weeks oh
let's get into this just gotta wait two
seriously
you thought you were just allowed to
travel free daddy yeah
wait what yeah i didn't know that you
thought you were allowed to just jump
the pond for freedom
yeah i thought yeah so it's in europe i
know
europe's locked down they're opening now
but
in france a man can't wear a beret and
have a little there's a new variant in
uk too you hear this fauci
came out and said this there's a new
variant yeah how long are we going to
buy in the factory huh no is there
another one
well according to you know he's trying
to you know keep his job you know he's
trying to
go oh man did you get the vaccine yeah i
did yeah i did yeah i didn't want to
but i did i didn't either i didn't want
to just because it's like nobody knows
like i'm not not against it i'm not like
an anti-vaxxer but you don't
know like i was actually i was online
for the vax
and i'm texting friend i was like 10
away and like you know they keep calling
and i'm like yo should i be i was
texting comics going should i do this
i would text the comedians dick jokes
and strip malls
should i be doing this and my [ __ ]
friends who were on the right were like
no
[ __ ] i had one friend go don't take that
homo juice
i had a friend tell me don't take that
home i go dude what
[ __ ] that is you'd be sucking
or it's going to help me or it could
really help
unfortunately unfortunately i can't take
the homo juice
and i'm just on the phone what the [ __ ]
and then i had like friends who were on
the left
side of my hands yeah that's out of my
hands
who's like one of my dearest friends you
think i should you think i should do it
he goes
oh 100 it's it's science and i actually
took that as if he was a
medical doctor like he's vouching yeah
yes
my
when not telling dick jokes my primary
research
it's unbelievable it's so yeah but stars
is more my special
i like when people go i don't i don't
trust it man i don't try we've seen this
before
why have we yeah yeah i don't trust it
why not well well tripoli i you know
i could do a podcast conspiracy social
club where i
sam triply hits me with conspiracy
tonight debunked them and it's
just it turns into a shout fest every
time it's great but
tripoli's like vaccine shedding bro i'm
like
what do you mean he goes you can be near
somebody who has the vaccine
and it will render you infertile that's
the plan
population control i'm like is there any
measurable evidence how do you
i don't know how did he get there oh
dude it's called youtube
yeah we can go down the rabbit hole yeah
you can't it is
it is a little dicey how fast it rolled
out i mean operation warp speed was
great by trump but
it is a little weird how do you have a
month later like we have something i was
like oh i guess i'll take it i guess
but the side effects sometimes can be
pretty heavy but that's that's for
chain got it oh i was [ __ ] up dude oh
you were last night
last night it just hits you when you
sleep did you take the johnson johnson i
took the modern
day that's what i got first team all my
turn up you got it you got to we got
modular too madonna yeah i want that
johnson johnson just to make it right
i'm getting next oh daddy don't get that
the one shot yeah because
it [ __ ] people up it gives you like a
third iron you haven't heard this give
your third eye
right yep
well i didn't hear actually i don't know
if you know this but like uh
like eight or nine very wealthy women in
connecticut took it and
all of them gave birth to black babies
they did
yeah oh i've heard that yeah yeah and so
they're enforcing diversity in the womb
you're doing
yeah but the problem is you gotta wait
two weeks now you gotta wait a month for
the johnson johnson two weeks for the
fire so my whole trip is oh
my whole trip is in jeopardy i can't
believe you're you're a smart guy yeah
yeah you're a smart guy
i can't believe nobody in your circle is
like hey dude you know you can't travel
international that backstage well no you
i you question
i was getting a vaccination with three
weeks to three almost four yeah three
weeks i have
um with three weeks to go i'm gonna say
okay
problem is even if i get the johnson
johnson i didn't know this they make you
wait a month you have to wait a month
here we go
see if it works meaning europe's going
to make you wait a minute wait we have
to see if it takes because it's not
because
oh there's respect now it's a low risk
that it doesn't take yeah but i've
already had covets so that
that sometimes there's a loophole there
so i can get just so i can't go some if
i didn't have the modern shots and i
want to go to italy tomorrow i can't
you cannot go i did not know it i did
not know
it's country by country like some of
them are lucy goosey and then
especially okay they tell you before you
book your ticket though
i did they didn't tell me yeah because i
went to hawaii and they gave me a whole
protocol of like
something like a national deal yeah you
don't think internationally they would
tell you what you need to do before you
didn't tell me when i bought my tickets
i spent a lot of money on my tickets who
booked your tickets
me no you didn't you've never booked
ticket in your life
someone else might get a touchdown man
what else
paul versus everybody uh the the cards
can be duplicated they're like people
are saying that the cards
are like it's like a little it's like of
course it is
like it's not laminated it's not it's
it's it's no it's
not mine right here have you seen it
like the
no but i might have to make up a call
it's just like yeah
it's like bigger than your wallet so it
won't fit it's it's
all right yeah you know what i got some
friends in the underworld
number there's a lot number from the
batch of the
vaccines where it traces back to where
you got it oh okay but
they can figure all that stuff out yeah
but but you know now and start you know
because june
15th la opens because then the virus
decides to leave on the 15th
but all right like starbucks you go in
and says if you're vaccinating you don't
have to
have to have a mass oh my god go and
have my mess and then they'll go are you
vaccinated i'm like oh you think people
are actually going to tell the truth
oh they're going to they so they ask
it's the honor system yeah i'll get the
[ __ ] out of here
you're gonna lie did you have any side
effects uh
no i just had chill i had like a little
chills after the second dose
yeah first dose nothing no second dose i
felt like i was like getting a little
sick
i i was getting pissed dude yeah what
the [ __ ] i i don't have i have
i had antibodies a year later too they
said so they think i caught it twice
they don't really have it twice it's
funny the way you told us you
when you found out you caught cove i
don't think
yeah like rudy gobert let me know that i
was covered positive i was just he was
the first one he's the reason that big
went into lockdown he's the reason that
they couldn't have any fans
yeah he said he's like i can't smell
anybody else not smell her taste and i
went downstairs in my
you know laundry room i smelled fabri uh
put febreze in my face couldn't smell it
woke my wife up three o'clock in the
morning i can't smell [ __ ] she's like
what that's not even
and i was like yeah no it's a rudy
gobert the jazz just
she's like who she's like [ __ ] where
do you go he's not
he's [ __ ] francis you got to be bald
deep in the basketball
let me go back you might be defensive
player to here
when you're there playing in the air
yeah get some friends
what brought you to l.a besides this
glorious podcast uh
a bunch of [ __ ] a bunch of podcasts uh
i'm doing uh
me and bill bird do the anything better
podcast so we're doing this is the first
episode that we're going to be
together together because we've been
doing it on zoom for so long
and uh and then i'm flying uh friday uh
to austin i'm doing the uh
vulcan uh great gas company i'm doing
that friday saturday it's cool
all right it's like you're performing at
a slipknot concert yeah
the background's like all like steel and
there's people are you know bleachers
and [ __ ] oh it's cool it's like cool
yeah it's cool yeah oh yeah it's great
have you done have you done the albany
funny bone
it's one i mean i shouldn't probably say
this but the albany funny bone and the
syracuse funny bone are two of the
[ __ ] worst rooms
in the united states of america and if
you don't have me back i i i would
[ __ ] thank him
i'll be there you're gonna put me in a
[ __ ] mall next to a dave and buster's
yeah it was the [ __ ] lowest people on
earth are in [ __ ]
have you done a connecticut funny bone
uh yeah that one that one i don't mind
as much as
the one the hartford one the harper one
is like it was scheduled to do
i was gonna do that me and dub david are
for doing i'm bringing double up with me
uh we're doing june 18th and 19th albany
funny bone
but i don't know my agent's like it's a
great it's an a room uh
what was your assessment again you just
told me it's the two worst rooms
no no syracuse's stuff i've done
seriously well sarah
listen before like um now over the last
like two years i started moving tickets
a little bit so when i was there
they were the room seats like 500 one of
the rooms the one in syracuse it's
almost five it's a big boy room so they
would yeah so they would like give
discounts and paper and then those
people but it's in a mall
and it was just it hurt your feelings no
and then and then yeah dude yeah
and syracuse you're next to a sharper
image
i went shopping at target before my set
dude i had
cinnabon
[Music]
my wife's like can you get toilet paper
i'm like yeah i got 10 minutes before i
go on
yeah i'm gonna drive up from from new
york i guess from the city
you know those ball gigs are so
depressed well well upstate new york is
is depressed in general man that whole
state yeah
the whole stadium is yeah [ __ ] yeah
like the opiate issue
all that stuff entire towns died because
damn you know
let's take a little break from the chat
with paul verzie because guess what man
for far too long wall street has
neglected the average investor
i'm talking about the people like
us giving out the same old generic
advice like buy index funds meanwhile
for the ultra wealthy they get access to
premium investment strategies
and white glove service that divide and
sit well with titan so they built a
premier
investment firm but for all of us thanks
to titan now everyday investors can have
their capital invested
like a world-class investment firm all
through the titan mobile app
titan's goal is to give you access to
the best investment experience in the
world but without the high minimums
lockups or performance fees their
in-house investment team invests your
capital using their award-winning
strategies
delivers daily research updates via the
titan app it's like having an elite
investment manager in your pocket
type manage hundreds of millions of
dollars for 25 000 clients
and counting and we're named the 2020
top investment app
of the year by us news to get started
download the titan app right now
start investing with titan today get
three months with zero fees
visit titanvest.com fighter that's three
months with
zero fees at titan vest v-e-s-t
dot com slash fighter you know you see
my thick ass and zoo culture like what
shorts is you wearing i'm wearing ten
thousand i've been wearing the seven
inch interval short with the inliner the
most
versatile they have man tons of features
all right
uh versatile their shirts are dope
they're lightweight perfect get
perfect for hit training circuit
training or just getting swole
in general they sent me one i love it
it's black you see me all the time in
zoo rocking this thing
all right um 10 000 makes the highest
quality best fitting most comfortable
training shorts
i've ever worn at the core 10 000 are
three core training shorts
built for all the ways you train they
got intervals short foundation short a
session short
then they spread out and whatever
workout you're doing they got you
covered
10 000 direct consumer company no
middleman so you get premium
quality fabrics trims techniques that
the other brands are gonna up charge for
so you don't want that man they have
over 9 500 5 star reviews
10 000 is offering you guys 15 off your
purchase
go to ten thousand dot cc enter the code
fighter to receive 15
off your purchase that's 10 000
t-e-n-t-h-o-u-s-a-n-d
dot c-c enter the code fighter
for 15 off this episode of firing the
kids with paul version is brought to you
by the best supplement company on the
planet we talk about on it on its
supplements
my boy gave me uh some pre-workout from
another supplement company and i'm gonna
[ __ ] my pants
and i think gimme kelvin i don't know
but i should have stuck to what i always
use i always use on it whatever they got
it always mixes well with my body
because they're the best i always trust
them
i don't have to guess what's in the
bottle or what i'm taking i know it's
the best supplements on the planet
from freaking shroom tech to krill oil
to alpha brain they got protein powders
creatine
they even got coffee whatever you're
looking for on it offers it they offer
it at the highest levels
protein bars protein bites plant-based
protein if you're a plant lover
we got all elk ballers warrior bars we
got streaming fitness home fitness so
you don't have to go to the gym
the best kettlebells you ever freaking
put your big
dick beaters on in the world they got
onyx kettlebells
primal kettlebells everything you need
sandbags battle ropes
like i said home fitness streaming
fitness on demand on in 30. go to
honor.com
fighter for 10 off the best supplements
on the planet that's on it.com
fighter 10 off because damn you know you
know i'm a big i'm a big uh
big big die hard knicks fan and my son
lucas is too and i was like i told my
wife i got back from
tampa and i was away my kids get sad
when i go away and [ __ ]
you know you know and so i got home and
i said to my i said i'm gonna take lucas
to game two or the play now i never been
to a next playoff game and that and
and he never has obviously so i was like
i'm gonna take him into game two
and uh we go down there and it was
[ __ ] it was amazing
it was the only game they wanted the
series the environment was something
i've never felt before
ever the the the three things that were
the most electric i've ever seen we all
went to duke unc
at duke uh i was at game one of the
world series yankees mets yankees
yankee fan they won in extras and this
just beat it this beat both oh wow this
beat both like
when i tell you the guard and it was
like the second time second day ever
they allowed 16 000 in the garden since
pandemic people
so when i tell you it was [ __ ] there
was
there was an alley-oop from half court
and everybody's going oh it's too high
he's not going to catch it
and [ __ ] he took two hand and yoked
it when i tell you the [ __ ]
i could feel it now the place my son my
son he's like
he was like two days before 12 and he
just goes let's [ __ ]
dude he was like
but the point of the story is the
homeless around there like my son was
you know
like it was more than normal like new
york city right now is [ __ ] up west
village
a woman was eaten somebody just came
with a crowbar smashed the window cut
her back up
like it's still going on like in pockets
but
my son was like holding my hand looking
at me and then it was like
lines of homies that i haven't seen in
new york in a long time so yesterday
the the sheriff so the city council
member is held in a press conference
down on the boardwalk in venice now the
boardwalk and venice down here
is a de facto champion it's the walking
dead what happened was venice said
i said you can live on the beach because
it's run by l.a shout out to
mayor garcetti and council member mike
bonan
who do nothing right so la runs it so
all of a sudden
everybody who's anybody all over the
country realizes you can sleep on the
beach in venice
so now there are three tents whatever
it's shantytown down there
what so so people get stabbed people get
when you go down there people are naked
they're
people are mentally deranged they're on
drugs it's a disaster
and the council member is down there
giving a press conference on what to do
and almost do [ __ ] like naked comes up
with a knife
this woman and tries to kind of stab he
comes up and starts so he they got to
get the cops
so finally the sheriff sheriffs have a
lot of power in counties
sure yeah and the sheriff of valley
county
came down and goes so this is nonsense
this is
nonsense i'm clearing the whole [ __ ]
thing out by
july 4th really yeah and so he goes if
you look at
it stops at santa monica and it stops at
marina del rey why
because they run their own city yep and
only venice so he goes and so now
i'm coming in and all the homeless
advocates and most people are you can't
do you don't have that jurisdiction
that's cool that's great
this is nonsense no we can't live
yeah because you have because there's a
narrative that says oh this is a housing
issue
and a and a wealth pay gap issue this is
a [ __ ] mental health
because it now now with how politically
divided we are there's a line in the
in the sand yeah and it's and if you
even even come close to hinting
that you're not you know feeling for the
people that don't have a place to
meanwhile it's violent it's not good but
it's not good but if you say that
you're like not compassionate you should
be allowed to set up a tent
uh a whole home structure yeah on a
public beach where kids and other people
are going
and taking a [ __ ] and then what about
those places of business that can't
make a dollar now they're having major
problems and their entire life savings
are
in that yeah no one wants to know what's
happening now those people not count
yeah or what about the people that spent
their entire life savings
buying to buy a house in venice it's
expensive as [ __ ] dude yeah but now the
property value's down
they can't leave that's right yeah you
know what i'm saying it's true
i can't sound my place yeah i mean you
know so i don't have any
so what are you talking about it has
nothing to do with compassion it has
nothing to do with this is
nonsense but if you have compassion like
you you hear these business owners
stories
yeah how about that because because
there's piss everywhere and you smell
human and they also contribute to a
society yeah so who are we going to
protect yeah it's the economy
[ __ ] and tourism is dead down
there good you don't want him to bite me
i don't want to fight him it is it's
also that these people
are actually a lot of them are truly
mentally ill
addicts yeah a lot i don't know why we
don't think like they're
just like [ __ ] getting high and
that's their [ __ ] yeah and they need to
get into a treatment center that you
can't
you can't if you're an addict and you
want to you're not allowed to set up a
whole
uh meth den right there
you're enabling them by doing nothing
but
it's nonsense something has to be done
so how do they stop what do they do so
what they do with it if they do if they
share it out we'd all be wavering the
sheriff's coming down there that was
what they're doing is they're going down
there and they're going 10 by 10 going
so you got to get out of here you know
that we're getting you out of here
that's happening that fixed the venice
problem yeah so now what we're going to
do is you here are there are options for
treatment and options for
where you can go and stay shelters
problem with shelters is addicts don't
want to go to shelters
they can't get dry and a lot of them uh
are
except women and children only i think
that's something that's true
yeah some of those shelters yeah yeah
and so
it's a real thing and there's like yeah
like because i guess uh
a lot of times the women they'll get
like abused and yeah they get raped
they get raped and stuff in those days
they said the only like major
metropolitan city that's done it right
was houston because they attacked it 10
years ago
and now their homeless problem is they
don't have a problem right but they're
all they're like the only major cities
who addressed it 10 years yeah you're
right i didn't really see any when we
were out there
not at all there's a way to solve these
problems
mafia mafia takes care of the [ __ ]
you ever hear johnny light johnny and
chris uh chris
yeah but he was he wasn't kidding when
he said he was like if if john he said
if john gotti and those guys were
like de blasio and cuomo would be have a
talk or two like this wouldn't be
happening yeah and like there's kind of
true
there's kind of because i mean obviously
what the mob does i'm not trying to
condone but there's order
there's order there's like hey man we're
gonna we're gonna make sure the
neighborhood is clean i remember new
york
you're gonna give us a cut yeah yeah
yeah we're gonna make sure that that's
probably
probably that it's like paying taxes
yeah
i don't have the mafia running [ __ ]
calabasas right now than our [ __ ]
governor
i'd rather give them my money i have
some protection yeah if the mob is
running [ __ ] you're not gonna have
homeless people in the neighborhood
it's not gonna happen and in fact
notoriously when the mob lived somewhere
in that neighborhood there was zero
crime in there oh you're not you're
paying taxes anyway
how great would it be just to watch mob
dudes walk out of like a joint
and just walk up to homeless dudes go
come on get up get your [ __ ] out
move it get your head get it blanket
smells like [ __ ]
ruin my lunch
ran the city you know and it was a
different thing there were certain areas
and there were certain things you just
didn't do you didn't do it yeah
you'd have to like they weren't they
weren't like gang members where you got
to
worry for your safety like they only
[ __ ] with each other like their their
code was not to hurt innocent people
there was a family
there was a real strict order yeah there
was no like no women and children
yeah it was just like if this guy [ __ ]
up or gets out of line or
you know then something's going to be
done and that's it but but things were
nice
things were new york was new york had
the really bad in the early 80s you
remember like what the
graffiti was everywhere violence was
everywhere and then giuliani
giuliani was people forget giuliani a
real badass dude i know he's a little
crazy now
i'm not a real bad dude he changed so so
giuliani's father got shaken down by the
mob
yeah and so giuliana had a vendetta i
remember when julianne said if you
belong to an organized crime family in
this city i declare we are clearly
straight up you didn't have a stand
there unless you had you
paid a vig or you were involved with the
mob in one way or another so the fulton
fish market which was one of the biggest
fish markets in the world
it doesn't seem like a lot that's so
much money that's
like fishing it's a nice fish market you
know when they were running
all for the mafia coming back as we keep
talking about it he opened it up though
he opened it up to he opened a
construction to different companies and
he opened up the fulton fish market
i remember they set the whole [ __ ]
thing on fire the whole
fault in the market was burning to the
ground i remember when
there was smoke was on the news their
mom was like what we can't
you're taking it away well then we're
going to burn it down
have you ever seen that john guys on amy
it was john gutty and his son because
remember when he got pinched his son
they thought was going to take over
yeah they have the actual footage in
prison of the sun
come going to talk to his dad and saw
that so nervous and he's like you know i
don't want to be in this business
and and his dad just looks killer dude
no he's like you don't [ __ ] rat you
don't turn no he's like i'll stay
[ __ ] in here i'm not talking because
they're going to come after you again
don't you see and then he starts leaving
again and he's like no daddy's wiping
his eyes
he's looked at his dad like when his dad
his dad came out i think his dad got out
of jail
and like went into his room and he just
like he was like so like nuts
is my dad you know yeah and he looks at
his wall and he goes he sees a poster
and he goes oh the mets huh
he was yeah i like to mess dad and his
dad just goes i'm a yankee fan he goes
dude from that thing
if you love your dad even if he's a
[ __ ] mailman you're going to root for
if he's john gotti yeah you know
my [ __ ] dad got me into star trek
like he was all about star trek i was
like i guess i'll get it there were only
two times i saw those
guys in new york i remember i was at
cafe sorrento and the raven nightclub
was right next door right yeah so you'd
see a limo and you'd see some dude kind
of a burly looking guy with like a
earpiece in and he and then the only
time i saw anybody come in or out of
that place because we're always looking
for gotti to go in you know
and uh the only time i saw is i saw
these two guys about your size and built
like you
with suits on they were walking out
gorillas
on their way somewhere and i never
forgot i never
that's when you realize that you're not
you're not a tough guy or a knuckle
breaker and no i did it
i don't know you gotta show your respect
how'd you get there you gotta because
you gotta pay your uh
it's not like that you're protecting the
strings
right here i i would have had no choice
i don't know man that's so weird it's a
good fellas too man i don't know
why the show bro if you can't hang this
yeah and then i see a [ __ ] dick
always the desperate like i i was gonna
do this bit about like are all drug
dealers
gay because it's always like oh do i
have to suck dick to get
like why is always sucking like could it
be something else that's always like
dude i hit rock bottom dude
stuck in a dick in an alleyway why did
it like like could you
why did it happen it always goes to that
like every drug there's one thing
there has to be other options there has
to be
some gay drugs is that like in the book
it's like listen man you know i'm not
gay or anything but it does say you got
to suck my dick
i feel like that would be rock bottom
it's always it's always sucking it's
always like
even that like key peel sketch yeah like
judge jesse he was like he was also a
crack one
yeah like this and he's on his knee and
it's like why is it always
sucking dick why i think i think i think
you're straight
forward massage like dude you know what
you got to do
[Applause]
dry shaving by the way we started the
show you started the show yeah yeah
we're going
we're going we're gonna just start a dog
out there yeah we'll be kicking through
the internet how crazy it is
when's the last time i saw you so when i
met this is so cool when i met you
i was uh this is years ago because i
yeah i haven't worked with 2017
was it 27 i don't know it was 2017. okay
so four years
yeah so i was uh burke called me up and
goes hey you want to open for me at uh
it was stand up live yeah bigger one and
we go to the hotel to meet
and he's working the he's working at the
hotel he's working valet at the hotel
so you came up you were super nice like
hey what's going on i liked your shoes
and oh yeah i liked you jordans oh okay
and uh i got jordan's on now that's
funny
but you you came you came up to me and
you were like hey what's going on with
the girl we're at the comedy like oh
that's so dope like i'm a comedian too
saying bill came over and you become a
community and bill was like oh you want
to do time tonight
and and he he was like yeah so we we met
him that he came on stage you opened
like whatever you did great it was fun
it was a good time and then it was a it
was a great weekend and then
yeah and then like from afar i just saw
what you were doing and it's so
so it's kind of it's it's kind of crazy
yeah like that we're here because i was
yeah i was a [ __ ]
valet you you and burr were boys from
from new york
so no burr is from boston so but he came
up in the new york scene right i came up
in the new york scene
and uh like my first manager just like
kind of threw me i didn't even host he's
just like
i got a big one for you it's gonna be uh
rascal's comedy club montclair new
jersey it was like opie and anthony and
it was like burr's first
it was actually burst first like weekend
weekend for like him and he packed the
place up 400 people
and i think was this after the philly
rant this he he had like this that he
had like a few things happen i think it
might have been the philly thing but
and there's like 400 people and it was
thanksgiving eve i opened for
bobby kelly on the thanksgiving eve
wednesday and then bobby's like
he wasn't going to be there for the
weekend like oh someone else is coming
in albert's going to come in and do the
friday saturday after thanksgiving
so uh he it was 400 people dude and i
was like not even a host like i didn't
host i would just like do longer sets in
this
and i got on stage and like i guess he
heard me and he was like dude were you
the other guy on the show he's like i
was downstairs he [ __ ] crushed and
he's like i'm gonna watch you
so he just watched me we kind of just
stayed in contact that way and then like
oh 809 he was like hey man you want to
come on then we just became like super
super then he just became like my mentor
he's my son's godfather and [ __ ]
and uh yeah but he's like like we were
talking before when a guy like that
says you know like when he's john gotti
basically it was just
like he's drunk yeah like that that's
the thing i mean i'm not gonna suck him
off but yeah he's gone
if you're made he'll make it he'll make
it yeah yeah
when somebody like you know like that is
you know working with
you and was like hey like you but he
would say [ __ ] that like he saw
me like that the thing about bill is
bill is like even beyond stage
he's he's like ahead of everything so
like he told me like it was like [ __ ]
12 years ago i'm in my we're in a condo
i got a baby at home my wife you know
and i'm
featuring here and there for people
doing contests and shows doing the urban
circuit
and i worked with bill a couple times he
called me up and he's like yeah man so
you know i saw with you you're gonna
you're gonna headline you're gonna
you're going to sell out clubs and
you're going to get into theaters and
i'm going like this is 12 years i'm
going dude i'm making 400 dollars this
week what the [ __ ] is
that talking about yeah yeah he's like
no man he's like i i you know and
and he was and so and but but he never
would give it up until it was time to
give it up
like we were talking before he'd always
be like hey man good job this weekend
and then all of a sudden i think it was
like 2010 he's like dude watching what
you're doing is a beautiful and then and
then he started to be like yo man like
you're ready for a special and then and
then getting that from that means more
like when
colin queen gives you a compliment those
guys give you come those are guys that
like
that's why like i'll be honest with you
i didn't get in this business for
podcasts or to be a radio host i got in
this business because eddie murphy
i got in this business because i saw
eddie murphy raw not delirious for me it
was wrong
my dad took me at uh live no it was in
movie theaters
oh and my my my grandmother and mother
i'm 42. okay my grandmother and mother
like you can't take them to see raw
you know it was like 1987 and my dad
loved comedy my dad took me to see
rodney dangerfield
i saw the rock concert in dc oh did you
yeah
yeah and he took me and i was like that
was it game like beverly hills cop
you know 48 hours yeah everything was
like eddie eddie was everything so
uh and then and then getting into this
and and doing this was just like that
was that was it for me like seeing that
[ __ ]
that was yeah that was that's that's why
you know and then now here i am
20 years professional for like 16 but
you know it was it was always stand up
first so for me it meant more
stand-up meant more like you know i see
a lot of people going out for followers
and doing [ __ ] and there's some
certain things you know burr also said
to me another thing that he was right
about he's like
it's gonna take a guy like you longer
because he knows my approach you know
i'm a family dude but i'm just not a
dude that's gonna [ __ ] pour your put
on lipstick and [ __ ] run out and do a
man on the street my underwear
and listen if a [ __ ] dude gets
followers doing that and they sell out
doing that like that's i'm not i'm not
hating on that but for me
i love when my fans are like oh versus i
love your approach man like you're just
you're just it's a real genuine thing
i love your stand up and and so forth
the old school approach
more like the the traditional comic
approach really but i'm also like i
adapted like i built a podcast studio in
my home yeah i
i do you know i have fun on podcasts i
love doing them but it's just kind of
like
you know i love i just love get i love
seeing the development of standup i love
seeing
yourself get better from album to first
special now i'm shooting my next special
in september and it's like that's the
where are you shooting in september i
think i'm actually funny i think i'm
going to shoot it at this 400 seater in
west niagara
i might shoot it a little you know i
live in westminster
i've done that club yeah so rosie
o'donnell did an hbo there they have a
giant stage
it's like a giant stage it almost looks
like a little theater and then it goes
up a little bit and it's like a 400
seater and i haven't done that club i
was supposed to do and i canceled
that's right it's it's actually cool
it's supposed to be a good club it's
actually i did my first one at the
terrytown music hall
which i love it's like a you know it's
like a thousand seater but this one with
covert responsibilities
and i'm ready to go so we just got to
get it where are you gonna where is it
gonna be
distributed uh i can't i could i can't
say but i'm scared yeah i'll tell you
all fair
yeah i'll tell you all fair but it'll be
on a major it'll be on a major streamer
and i know that it's better than the
first one so
i can't wait for people to that's what i
had to say i had to sit on it
for like i had to sit on it but like you
know having my peers going this next
one's this next one's yeah
so cool i was thinking about eddie
murphy eddie murphy might be the only
comic ever
to have been that good that young
to be to be to be to have had you're
talking about he was on
snl when he was 19. and the country was
talking about him yeah
and the whole country was talking saved
the show too i mean the show
and then and then stand up i think it
was dove was talking about this like
stand up is the only
you know very few times where you have a
very young person write an amazing novel
and i think stand-up is very similar you
don't really see people get
get their voice until they're in their
30s you're not when you're young right
it's very you don't have perspective
yeah you can be funny you can be like
raw [ __ ] yeah yeah you know but but i
mean it's really hard to kind of
be a comic where people go off but
eddie murphy man he when he was 20 20.
yeah i feel like that too i feel like
you you you do it in your 20s
i feel like you get good at it in your
30s and then i think if you if you have
a career and you were fortunate enough
to get
past that then you become 40. yeah then
you become one of the dudes but like
eddie i agree with you brian like eddie
when he did his drunk uncle or his
grandfather oh god
he put you in a mental you're in a movie
like you're like you no longer saw eddie
you saw the drunk father
you saw the drunk father and then he's
doing it and he's 20 something years old
and his wife can't leave the house yeah
he's doing it so he's funny
and he's somebody else related such a
good actor you're just such and then he
just stopped yeah
he just stopped i think he's so rich and
he started famous
i have a couple theories on it one let's
hear it he got super rich
and he got i think he started smoking
weed all the time
24 7 and sometimes that can kind of like
it kind of
it kind of dulls you a little bit it
kind of kind of depends how you are but
i think with
him in that sense i think the
combination of being high
all the time with all the money i think
i think it was more of all the money for
him yeah and as a comic you just need
that thing that i think that's why kevin
hart's a beast because think about he's
basically similar career to eddie right
like major movie stars
maybe five bigger movie stars in the
world than kevin hart yeah and still
tours like a [ __ ]
have yeah he still does clubs he has
writers but i'm just saying still
you know especially i did from his house
you know pretty relatable you know
unless you have kids i think
he's still doing it yeah he's kevin's
always stayed hungry but i think eddie
was also afraid from what i heard
he was also afraid that his old
anti-homophobic old homophobic stuff
and also the fact that he got kind of
caught picking up somebody who was
in drag that was stuff that he was
he was worried he was going to get
called out on and he didn't want to i
heard another thing too that it was
a a lot of people were just shouting at
him on stage like he was just so famous
steve martin said that steve martin said
i knew i had to stop doing comedy when
you know he's doing his egyptian thing
with the guitar and the the
his closing thing with the
and whatever the stage manager messed up
the guitar didn't come down
and the crowd's dying laughing he's like
i didn't say anything i haven't done any
stand up yeah they're laughing at this
[ __ ] like they should be upset cause
they paid all this money
and then they were shouting my lines
before i could get them out he's like oh
yeah stop doing this like yeah the
ride's over or right yeah
right a whole new house yeah i guess
with eddie they were shouting like
stuff from his movies adam said but
steve are saying they were shouting his
old stuff yeah not this crap
he's like dude he's like dude this isn't
what i'm doing
yeah i get out i think too what you said
too i think eddie is so eddie's been
famous for 40 years on the level of fame
like
we we think that some of these youtube
people are famous like this is like
eddie is like tom cruise famous yeah
eddie is like there's a level of fame
and he's there in comedy we're with very
few
you could even say above chappelle and
like eddie murphy's [ __ ] eddie murphy
like
i would say he's bigger he's on a
different he's eddie different
stratosphere
yeah eddie murphy's like the [ __ ]
michael jackson of comics i agree
and it's like an iconic so talented he's
so deeply he probably is afraid of
expectations but i think he's especially
now i think he should just if he loves
it if
he really really loved it and wanted to
do it he would be doing it and just put
that aside he's probably just like he
probably thinks it's not
enough to gain i think you're what you
just said is he's he's worried about
expectations it's really hard to kind of
like you know he was gonna he was gonna
do
he started to do it like he was booking
clubs and stuff to get back into it
because
he i guess he would throw a party like
once a month or maybe once a week and
kevin hart and all the big dogs would go
to it and kevin hart on his uh serious
show was like i'm telling you
he's the funniest guy in the room yeah
so finally he was like yeah i'm going to
do it and we're like yeah and then covet
hit
so it shut it down so i don't know if
he's going to revamp it yeah i know he
was thinking about doing because he was
talking about it on convenience and cars
with coffee
yeah but that was before the pandemic so
he had a whole plan right and remember
before damon wayne's
remember he was starting to he's there
there was rumors that he's popping up at
clubs
that at the commie store they didn't
announce that they said special guest
star so all everybody thought it was all
the comics
the whole crowd thought it was eddie
murphy they're doing wrong i love damon
wayne's yeah yeah and when he walked in
i was like
my heart for him it was like oh yeah i
remember
he could have the hottest 10 minutes
right now like and it
doesn't matter because you're not eddie
murphy
all the comments were there and it
didn't go well and i was like oh no
then he was up in the green room
backstage and i just went up and i was
like what's up legend man
you know they were like
why the [ __ ] would eddie murphy go like
that if it's any movie no matter who it
is you're gonna be disappointed like no
matter who
it's like like frank gorilla grew up was
telling a story about how he grew up
pretty really poor
and his dad he they they were gonna buy
a like a car
and it was like some kind of a like it
wasn't a cutlass but it was like this
new
model you know chrysler some [ __ ] and
they were looking at the pictures and
you know they had no money so they're
looking at pictures and frank's like
look at the interior there's leather and
we got wheels look at the wheels man
there's shiny and he's like so excited
he's like we're gonna be able to drive
around the neighborhood in this he was
making plans you know it's like you feel
like
your dad has a car yeah and and it's and
he's you know back then he goes against
the car and they're waiting to see the
new car because they're gonna go to the
they're gonna go places in a car and
it's also like you know
it's this beautiful shiny limo looking
car and he said
they pulled up and the wheels were that
big and it wasn't black it was brown
it was [ __ ] brown and the interior was
[ __ ] brown
and and frank goes like this frankly
he's with his mother he goes
that's not the car and he's
to start to cry and his mother grabs his
hand and she goes off
she goes your father will never own his
car
and you act excited and frank was like
yeah
dude what a gangster mother by the way
it's like when i turned 16 my best
friend joyce nagel
his his his family got him this i'll
never forget this
this volkswagen golf and it was like
lime green it was the coolest thing
and then he was like bro you're next
your birthday isn't too much bro
i know i heard your dad i'm like no way
he's like yeah bro
so his 16th birthday it's a wednesday
night on my own pulling school tomorrow
with me so [ __ ] sick
my new car i i'm not making that i swear
my dad hands me a gift
i figured you know you're not gonna put
you know put a picture of a car so i
figured the keys
were in the box and it was like a box
like this and i'm are you crazy dad i
open up
i swear it was a bike seat oh cause i
rode bikes it was a bike seat
it was some bike seat that had like
suspension on it dude i opened up
and i started crying and my dad goes oh
you were happy yeah it goes
oh hey dad my dad goes i didn't think
it'd be this big of a deal it's just a
bike seat but i'm like
my son appreciate it my parents enjoy
him like
i call my rejoicing i'm not getting a
car man he's like what do you give him
like a bite seat he goes oh that's cold
my parents were the they were the world
heavyweight champion of bad gifts the
world heavyweight champion
they've gotten my dad traveled a lot
they're in switzerland
i'm like you're going to bring me back a
swiss army knife because
all i care about is knives i'm i'm nine
so how cool is this
i got plans because i'm going to go
camping yeah it's not gonna do [ __ ]
yeah of course not but the only thing in
my head is swiss army knife yeah i want
the thick one because
that's all and they brought me back a
[ __ ] sweatshirt my mother
my mother used to you think i'm kidding
my mother used to wrap lamps
from the attic and so i had something to
unwrap i can't i can't my father gave me
his [ __ ]
so like my father liked his change right
happy birthday i had that from when i
was a teenager
i'm like just she i didn't realize like
i thought he was being sentimental but
it was a jeep [ __ ]
he's like one day you're gonna have this
coat
this coat we're in here hey at least
you're new though my dad grew up in the
broad i was born in yonkers
and then i've always been like a
westchester kid right you know always
always right outside
the city and [ __ ] but my father is uh my
parents got divorced i was five my
father's a 100 percent
like i know people have talked about
their sicilian fathers i know sebastian
has talked about it
chrissy d talks about it yo my father is
another [ __ ]
i'm sorry my father is old school i mean
my father
is like he you're not a man to him
if you don't have like shoes and a watch
that
pop my father my father would go to a
pizzeria i told a story the other day my
father was walking on pizza room like
100 dollar gators
and a [ __ ] and a shirt and he had
these my father had big gaudy sunglasses
even in the in when it's dark yeah yeah
you know and he just had to [ __ ] around
just had the [ __ ] yeah
oh
yeah yeah
drinking beer tattoos all that to him
was yeah
like that [ __ ] yeah nice legacy like
yeah
it needed to be it needed to be artie
lang's dad wouldn't let you
open his cadillac door if you had rings
on you go you got rings on let me open
this door you can scratch the paper
yeah my grandfather was 100 sicilian so
oh wow
the idea of what a man was yeah and
class
yes like the all happened to those
people yeah like
that to me that's cool oh yeah that's
what it is
there's a very there's a real discipline
to the southern italian kind of like
a culture there's a there's a there are
there are it's not so much that there
are rules there are principles that you
never break right like it's like
laws what is that that whole thing laws
are for regular people
but there are rules and you never break
rules yeah there's also a sense of
respect dude like yeah man
i would never leave the house in sweats
you're never gonna see me on sweatshirts
never ever he would get mad like because
i was just a kid like see my dad would
talk to me
at a very young age the way you you
should talk to an adult
yeah he treated me and my brother like
that but almost like detrimental like
you know he would always
he would just say things like like you
know my parents got divorced got
divorced
and he'd be like yeah man your mother
you know just she turned evil
like the devil invaded us the devil
invaded the house
i gotta go home i live here
like i gotta go sleep with the devil i
gotta go the devil's not
taking care of me tomorrow the devil's
making my [ __ ] lunch
your mom crazy you know she went crazy
it happened sometimes yeah
you know we have a good night yeah yeah
yeah yeah i was like so it was like 19
and you know
divorce for sicilians is like it's like
1982 yeah
they don't do it no no no no stay
together you stay together man yeah it
was against the church it was against
the whole culture
like family was everything sundays you
had yeah sundays of my grandparents
house
you sat down there was a whole meal
there was a whole way yeah
yeah but it was number one thing from my
dad though um so
like in in the 80s the courts didn't
give the the man
the you know it was tough for the father
and and still is
it still is but like my father got like
11 no no abuse no cheating
just a bad bitter divorce and my father
got
11 hours a week with me and my brother
so he had he had eight hours on sunday
he would pick us up on sunday at night
it was a week he would pick us up sunday
at noon and he would drop us off after
dinner at eight
and then we were with him on wednesday
from five to eight so my relationship
with my father is like you know my
father's down south now he moved after
which is a whole other story my father
moved after seven years in the bronx
he's in west palm beach florida
and he keeps calling me to tell me how
different florida is
so he'll just go paw paw and my dad gets
real big with intros
how you doing hey
everything's good he always starts out
everything's good listen
listen like he answers four questions
that weren't asked to him
why don't good everything's good he
always tells me where he is i'm still
down here in florida i know he moved
there
i'm down
they got spiders down here like like
prehistorics
that's my fault i'm being dead like this
is not for the pockets it's not gonna be
funny
this is not to be funny this is my fault
this is my father man
like to the like my father you know like
old but he's like night like he's like
nice racist
yeah you know like he's just like it's
just he's like grandfathered in where
he's not
just because of the neighborhood yeah
but i've seen him with all different
cultures and he's fine yeah but he's
just it's just like the neighborhood he
grew up basically like in a bronx tale
yep so it was like that my my
grandfather grew up in bensonhurst that
was my mother
no he grew up in the bronx near like
actually on the border of like uh
uh yonkers like he grew up near like
arthur avenue and [ __ ] like that but he
just has that
you know like his my father still can't
believe obama was president
[Applause]
like he'll say some wild [ __ ] and then
just try to push him
it's about family though what did he do
for a living
he was in uh he's car insurance real
estate yeah and he always had cash he
was just one of those
my grandfather always cash yeah is that
is that a thing money clip yeah you have
a credit card
credit cards for suckers you pay you pay
a thing so he always had cash
always cash now kids it's like cash like
yeah
here's the thing so what he cared about
though what he cared about most
was and my father always want meals food
right
and and he would get a restaurant for us
on sunday because he's with his boys and
we would always go to like a nice
restaurant
but my father could be real rough on
wait staff right so i'm actually i want
to put this in the new hour because he
he couldn't handle that i brought my
family here on sunday my kids who i
don't get to see
it needs to be right right so like veal
he's big veal
but he likes it big it needs to be a big
cut right so if it comes out small me
and my brother could see him
look right and and if and and his first
bite
will dictate the rest of the evening my
father makes
my father make sound effects when when
my father makes noises and [ __ ] when he
eats
so if it's good you could just go oh
oh oh like you know like that yeah one
time i knew it was bad
right i knew it was he just goes he goes
and he puts it in his mouth and me and
my brother saw and i'm like dude i
should go to the bathroom
and then he'll go to the waiter and be
like listen he actually said one time he
goes i brought my family here i can't
i wrote my family bro
yeah it gives a [ __ ] that is like it's
like the world
cutlet insults the way i've been living
my life
yeah so that so that's who like i kind
of grew up with actually not really
i was five and then like that's who i
kind of older younger brother
my brother christian is five years older
you know a good example of
sicilians is that like my grandmother
always say what's right is right you
know what's wrong was wrong it's very
simple like there were things and so
yeah they they stopped going to the
church
a long time ago they stopped they just
stopped there like nobody was religious
you know nobody nobody but they're
catholic so
even though my grandparents my parents
stopped going to the church there's no
church
there's no praying there's nothing
there's a crucifix
there's a crucifix in your room and when
i was 13
the priest came to the house to give me
my confirmation oh wow so regardless
even though nobody really believes in
going to church or even
nobody talks about jesus christ i still
had to get confirmed
it's like a culture yeah it's you know
it's it's culture is culture man
i got baptized as as greek because my
mother's 100 greek oh wow
and my dad like there was no like you
know the dunked in the water and all
that stuff
but my son lucas and my son lucas and
sophia
uh my son and daughter lucas and sophia
my dad said you know like you just said
my dad said to me
and he said it as serious as you could
imagine he was dead serious he goes paul
you know
i didn't hear anything about a
christening or a baptist baptism and he
just goes you know i just want to tell
you something it's really important and
my father would always say to me you
gotta
you understand what i'm saying he would
always understand what i'm saying
he goes listen he goes you know if if
they're going to make it to heaven
exactly as serious as
told somebody that they had stage four
kid he said to me he goes
you know if if you want them if they got
to get into heaven this needs to happen
so that's exactly like what that's
that's dead
my grandmother and my grandfather said
to my sister when she had her baby she
might they said they said get the kid
baptized
and uh my sister goes but you're not
what do you mean you know when was the
last time we were in church she goes i
know
just in case because because they might
because sometimes there's a chance they
could be in limbo
so you're not you're not in heaven yeah
we don't want confusion up there
these are not superstitious people by
the way but to them they were like
that's a very important thing it's it's
like a vaccination card into heaven
they point it up to an area like it
might be in limbo they they were like
it's like there's a lot of waiting you
know you know you're spinning around
and all you have to do is have every
head what just spin it around
dude he was i like sometimes i wish if
it was recorded i
my dad is so over the top with some
things that i feel like i would get
cancelled oh really because he's my
father
i'm just like i visited him but like he
said i'll do my father you got an
association
oh dude my father says my father's hella
my father you see what they did to trump
you see this and i'm like uh you know i
mean i'm not really watching i'm just
you watch your kids
watch your kids i
uh he's been in florida for like two
years now oh okay oh it's so fresh yeah
so
it's it's new and it's new for him so he
wants to talk to us and tell us
but here's the thing i know i'm painting
a picture of like this he's like like
educated and like so nice like if he met
you he would it would be like oh my god
how are you doing oh
you're friends with my son like he's
it's just like a it's just like this
instilled thing that they have from the
neighborhood
passed down from generation to
generation oh yeah yeah it's it's what
are you putting like never like keep
talking
i gotta appear i'm gonna die i'll retake
break yeah
he said i gotta be
take another break with our boy paul
verzie
because one thing that get me started
riding bikes on the road
was doing it in my garage on the peloton
i love the peloton
they have world-class instructors dope
music endless fitness variety i never
get sick of it
pelton has created an unmatched fitness
experience to keep my thick ass
motivated workout after workout
they robin's my favorite you the weights
they got dope music
cardio and strength like i said the
weights you can get one subscription for
the whole squad the whole family can
share one bike
their all-access membership is more like
a family plan with no additional cost
the class is for every level beginner
they have tabata programs peloton meets
you every step of your fitness
journey as you progress choose from a
wide range of cycling classes that meet
your level
keep you challenged every time you clip
in all right limitless class
variety endless variety live i like to
do it live
they have plus live and on demand
strength yoga stretching classes they
have weights they got it all
get started on your pelton journey right
now go to onepeloton.com to learn more
that's z o
n e p t
one peloton if you're a business owner
you probably know exactly what you do
with an extra day
in each week maybe launch a new website
spend more time marking your services or
find new more way creative ways to build
your brand but you don't need an extra
day
what you really need is fiverr
f-i-v-e-r-r
your one-stop shop for world-class
freelance talent with fiverr all the
freelancers you could ever need
are right at your fingertips fiverr
connects business like yours
with freelancers offering hundreds of
digital services
so you can stop feeling overwhelmed
start growing your business
fiverr's global network of on-demand
freelance talent is here to help whether
you're launching your first business
scaling your current business or need of
extra support graphic design
copywriting marketing web program film
editing
scoring music you got a youtube channel
whatever you got you're gonna find your
talent and begin working
on your project within minutes what
you're gonna find it's
instant it's easy 24 7 customer service
pricing is always project based not
hourly all right check out fiverr
f-i-v-e-r-r dot com receive temperature
off your first order by using the code
fighter find all the digital services
you need
in one simple place that's f-i-v-e-r-r
dot com code fighter again that's
fiverr.com codefighter
back from a hot piss break back from a
hot piss break guys i gotta meet your
father
yeah i have to no he's he would be you
would be like oh my god he's like the
nicest yeah
i just i just love that like florida so
much so i'm surprised we didn't run into
it i know right yeah
more times that we won lately like i
can't i like i keep laughing in my head
about these
grown man of the toyota yeah i was
[ __ ] telling you there's a story if
you guys want i'll tell you guys a story
i was gonna
i always had this story giannis alluded
to it a little bit on rogan but it's my
it's my story but he kind of got into
something my father this is 100 true and
i never told the full story on a podcast
if you want to hear my father's call
this is 100 true now this is not
[ __ ] in 1973
my father my mother my grandmother and
my aunt
saw a ufo over in yonkers and it was all
over and my father's
version of it might be the funniest
thing that my father
first of all my f my father saw a
[ __ ] all right
this is this is real my mother your
father and ufo together is just i'm
locked in
yeah so i'm i'm not even a thought it's
1973 my mother was pregnant with my
brother christian my mother was like 22
years old right
my grandmother uh yaya is what they call
your greek grandmother
she has little you know house in yonkers
and she had a lot and and it was like
to start the sun started going down and
there was like a tv room
and my father hears my grandmother
mother and aunt going oh my god what is
this like what what is this tommy get
out here you got to get out here
so my f and my father told me and my
brother this from young and still to
this day says he wished he didn't see
what he saw but he knows what he saw
and let me start off by saying my father
said that anybody
before this point that said they saw ufo
or aliens he thought that they were
crazy hillbillies that just wanted
attention he thought that they were
mentally ill
and he said that he goes i thought these
people were all [ __ ] crazy
paul i saw so he goes outside and he
says he sees over the thing they said
it's low and it was actually all over
newspapers the next day
says it was a low silent
silent [ __ ] thing and he said it had
like a blue
like a tin blue thing and he said there
was like little
portholes or something around and he
said he's looking at this thing and he
said
they're just [ __ ] staring at it and
he's going what the [ __ ] it's not making
noise
and he got real like scared and he's
going oh my he said to him he said
he goes i felt like i could either throw
a rock or if i had one of my shotguns
and then he goes
but then he goes i know these things
could read your [ __ ] mind
so i got scared i was thinking it so i
ran back in the [ __ ] house and i
started looking out the window
he's like because i'm not having those
[ __ ] things take me out
so he goes back outside right and he
said and he says he goes paul i swear
to god i said i would never lie to you
and your brother he still he's never
changed the story
and peop he's still to this day he said
in one [ __ ] second
it turned into a dot he said in one
second
this thing turned into a star and he
swears to me he took off
but he's going he's going paul i'm
seeing i'm looking at this [ __ ]
flying saucer
and it's sitting here and i haven't
heard somebody say flying saucer since i
got [ __ ] ice cream
he's going i'm [ __ ] he
[Applause]
this thing wasn't from this [ __ ]
world i could promise you that
whatever the [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] that
thing was it was not from this world i
promise you
i would never lie to my boys i thought
those people were crazy this and that
so it's 1973. so he tells my mother
you know it's sicilian he goes you don't
[ __ ] tell anybody
amanda you don't [ __ ] tell
anybody they're gonna think we're
[ __ ] crazy
if you don't i don't and like it was
like a code of like like now
when like now that it's out my father
always goes i don't i know
my mother i don't care i've always known
and like it's it's actually really true
so my father was uh before i probably
wouldn't be in comedy if my parents
would get divorced
my dad was like a big wig at aig down
the city they were looking at a 800
thousand dollar home
in 1982 right now right now
aig would provide insurance to insurance
companies
okay yeah yes yeah he was like and they
went they went
belly up during the crisis right they
didn't they i think i think but like
this is like 19 1970 my dad
they were huge just out of college and
he's what he's like they loved him and
he was like the guy
and he's making money and my father was
really but i think this is what my mom i
i guess i want to say they were just
different you know my dad won't come
home like fur coke at her fur coat
my dad would want to wear a rolex get
hurt my mom didn't care about that [ __ ]
my dad was very much like
we're going to take over we're going to
terry showed love we're going to get a
[ __ ] we're going to get a castle
we're going to get a boat like my father
thought that that was
what it was so he said they're at a
barbecue for aig
and they're they're they go they drive
down to long island and all the
companies there it's the 70s and
everyone's having a good time
and my mother goes tommy come here
let's t remember we saw the flying
saucer tell everybody the time and my
my dad like flipped like like just made
my mom look crazy because ah she's we
don't know what we saw the [ __ ] i told
you
my bosses these are my boy they're gonna
think i'm [ __ ] crazy and
but he did tell me he told me that um
and the way he described it was so funny
but he told me that
it bothered him that he saw it and that
he wished that he didn't because he
still
like he knew for the whole time like
during this that there was something
else out like he knew
and like it's [ __ ] interesting so now
that that it's out and
pilots and the government is going yeah
that's not from this world
he he always knew but he told me he sat
down behind my brother he's like it's
out there and like we saw it
and then my mom who's very kind of
religious and christian and remarried
we were like mom is it is it uh is it
true and giannis papa's got so [ __ ]
into this
he was like oh did you your mom i know
your dad but did your mom see so like he
came over to a family thing he went up
to my mom he goes
did paul told me did you really see that
and my mom who's even religious she's
like
she said i have to say yeah we saw it
like you don't see something floating
over your head
and then it turns into a [ __ ] star in
an instant
and say i didn't see that like or like
try to it is what it is religious or not
you saw what you saw
so uh and he said it just stayed there
he said
the two things that were consistent
always was that it it was silent
it was silent just hovering there and
then it was and it turned into a a
star in the sky the government's still
not saying it's aliens they're saying
it's a it is a ufo
which means unidentified flying object
yeah so they're saying we're the same
we're not confirming aliens we're saying
it could be a military drone could be
from china might be our military
could be an alien we don't know but that
jackie gleason story too i mean that
that i think that i don't think that
that's a lie you know you heard the
thing about jackie
oh jackie gleason was his wife wrote an
autobiography and she said he came home
one he was
very close with nixon he was very close
with nixon you know what they called
jackie gleason
because you're young the great one they
call him the great one they do he was
he was he was the honeymooners he was
the star of the honeymoon he was in all
the
programs he was one of the greatest
community comedic actors
maybe the greatest comedic actor and
they actually
they actually say that what his stand up
they said there was no video or audio
at the time they said he walked into a
[ __ ] they said he walked into a
comedy club and would just [ __ ] grab
the mic
and just light him up he was in how
about him in the hustler what did he
make oh
i heard he had he would have like they
said he would have like 12 scotches
throughout the day eat steaks all day
smoking the doctor was like and he was
like this is how i need each other and
he ended up getting to
71. but he was like that's so he was he
was they called him the great one
so what did he say to nixon so so him
and nixon were very very close i believe
it was nixon and his wife said
uh he came home pale as a ghost one time
and he said they took me to a naval base
and i saw them doing some [ __ ] on on a
living creature
on something that was not from here and
uh and that's that's a story
that's a famous story that he was close
to they put him down in a naval base and
uh and he saw some [ __ ] that uh
weren't meant for us to see yeah i don't
need to be brought down there
i don't wanna i'd love to see that [ __ ]
i'm all i'm all in yeah
oh you'd want to see it oh hell yeah
you'd want to see it and the president's
know what's up
on our on our podcast burgos versus what
would you say to them and i was like
he's like i go yeah i would just try to
talk to him and i
and i i just go yo you guys everything
good he goes
first of all he goes you can't start
with you
you're really going to start with slang
what to do
baby came out i would be i put my hands
up
just be like you know what's weird we
automatically because of movies and
books we automatically
assume they're just evil as [ __ ] they
might be really cool
yeah they might be dope they they say
that the idea would be that they're a
higher life form so that they are
looking at us like we're very yeah we're
very primitive it'd be like look at
these [ __ ] yeah
it's like the way we look at chimpanzees
yeah you know what you don't do with a
chimp bub
what do you do tell me real quick yeah
no
what do you not do to it turn your back
no uh
what's a sign of aggression what's the
sign of real aggression what
yeah showing your teeth yeah
smiling don't do this to a chimp
[Laughter]
you do that no they say wolves
and chips are like
joe zimmerman you know joe zimmerman
he's a comic he uh his his album was
called smiling at wolves because the
same thing with them
any time they anytime those predators
you know they see that [ __ ] they do that
they're
smiling at wolves and he's it's uh yeah
i don't ever want i'm not into the
[ __ ]
those [ __ ] like this you gotta know how
to talk to him so i think i was training
embarrassing
grizzly person how do you know and he
goes yeah they tell you if they're gonna
attack you if they're in a bad mood
how it goes grizzly bears click their
jaw and you just know to get the [ __ ]
out of there
that's what they do oh okay just let's
go into this guys yeah
yeah no click so we're good get the kids
the bear's not flicking get the kids
get the kids the bear's not gonna get
how many how many [ __ ] japanese
tourists their kids get killed because
they put their [ __ ] kid on top of the
[ __ ] bison
yeah yeah one girl got flipped by oh
yeah guys remember that yeah yeah
yeah don't go up to them did you see
that cougar going at that hiker in utah
yeah that was that scared me is that
recent because it was probably like
like six months yeah those are the
bikers and
it ate the one friend no no no this is
just one guy walking
watching he was seeing that one though
oh that guy yeah yeah and the guy's
going
and he was like yelling at it he kept
calling it bro yeah he was going
bro i think where he's going don't
[ __ ] do it
please but i would i like i was scared
for that you hear the bikers in
washington they were riding their bikes
and they saw like
it was a starving mountain lion and so
they were like oh we're gonna stop and
they say get real big and
bring so they put their bikes up there
and the mountain lion's like oh [ __ ]
yeah these guys stopped and it killed
them start attacking the one
[ __ ] them all up the friend goes [ __ ]
this noise i'm gonna go get help also
leave you hanging because mountain
lion's eating your ass first
yeah he goes around he'll get help the
mountain goes oh cool you want to run
well i like to chase
so i'm gonna leave this guy here goes
after the guy that went to run to get
help also ditch his friend
eats him alive another guy gets back and
then the cops come in
they see them outline they see the guy
the mountain lion dragged the guy up
into the tree i thought yeah they found
like his head
damn killed the mountain what the [ __ ]
that's like that's like did you see it
because you can't tell
that's what they say don't know the guy
the guy i think it's somewhere out near
edmonton he's running he's jogging
and mountain lion just comes out of
nowhere comes at him and he goes whoa
whoa
whoa whoa and sprays the [ __ ] out of it
and then goes like that
it's on youtube i think it's crazy they
don't they don't [ __ ] around a mountain
lion
150 pound mountain lion it's not a good
dude what do you hear about the guy
who's my bike don't pander
all sorts of animals and i saw a [ __ ]
bobcat
oh yeah and even that was alarming oh
yeah
yeah yeah no that's scary wait what
about um
yeah yeah did you see the video of the
guy choking out that choke the mountain
lion out this guy's running two cougars
up here
the man behind the camera phone is
donnie stone
what the [ __ ] he sent those in
gorgeous melorious man doesn't the
producer tell you
which ones to stick part and eventually
[Applause]
[Music]
i guess i would never go into
[ __ ] like that without a rifle or a gun
if there's grizzlies in the area or
cougars that seem to like humans
um going out there with my gun i got to
have a pissed all out got it
yeah you guys know bobby kell you know
bobby kelly yeah rob yeah
yeah yeah he's a deer he's a dear friend
of mine and he wants to go like
can't camping and [ __ ] and like you know
i was bobby does that's not i don't see
bobby he loves he loves to like he was
like you know and we went dude and it
was if i [ __ ] hate it every minute of
it
i was freaking out [ __ ] [ __ ]
and we're in the missouri uh the uh
missouri breaks or whatever it's called
and you're up in montana and it's it's
[ __ ] the middle of
what nowhere and i just you wake up and
you're sleeping the [ __ ] tent
on the ground your body's not used to it
and you're [ __ ] freezing
you're freezing right and i just hear
broken i can just hear my
he's listening to us and he's and he's
going his whole face is going shoo
as he's trying to talk exactly guys just
hear him he's like yeah
i have no desire yeah no i just hear god
yeah i just hear him go camping because
camping blows
and i'm like amen [ __ ] he was
all scared for me because i was
you know i see rattlesnakes and not
mines where i bike rides
and he goes uh you have a knife you're
not a [ __ ] knife
you need to do something so i go to the
studio the [ __ ] machete i'm like well
i can't
i can't ride my bike a [ __ ] night
from the [ __ ] medieval times
i'm gonna buy i have my broad
i bought a swiss army knife right like i
just went to the store and got like
basic [ __ ]
and when i got there i got a steak i got
a stick and i like i did one of those
things
and bobby goes yeah dude i saw the movie
the edge too
from the edge yeah
[ __ ] you think that you think that's
gonna work where's that i gotta have
something here
because i wanted to bring he's like you
can't bring a rifle you can't like yeah
there's animals there yeah
yeah i'm dying dude
he was like let's go again and i was
like yeah because like him and like ari
and them were like they all go out and
like they had like a whole and i'm like
and he's like i was like let's do a
cabin i was like i'll do a cabin then
we'll go fishing
yeah you know you don't want to do it
i'm not into it they want to sleep on
that [ __ ] ground i can't do it
i did it one time and i [ __ ] hate
them it's not funny somewhere i would
just worry about grizzly bears
no you see a mountain that [ __ ]
scared the show i'll tell you what
scared the [ __ ] out of me and my family
was uh when we went to montana last year
saw a moose like
straight up scary moves oh well they're
[ __ ]
enormous they're huge and my son he's
just seeing him on cartoons and books
like dad let's get out
and the guy driving goes no you don't
want to you don't want to get out
because we had a problem last season
with that they killed him i go
problem and she goes yeah i'll tell you
later i don't scare the kids i'm like
what the [ __ ]
yeah this is snakes for me dude snake
that's that's it i mean a pit viper is
not fun to get bit by right no the
these these rattlesnakes that i see the
first one i ever saw it was based out of
that movie anaconda
this thing was [ __ ] enormous they get
pretty big and i'm not used to them i
was
when i first started i'd see him every
day and i was so scared
and eventually like oh they're just
think about a [ __ ] they're not like
coming at you
they're literally just chilling
hopefully you don't run over one with
the bike but you
they're they're just doing that think
about a music dog think about a mean dog
i wore a bite suit
and yeah in afghanistan they let these
malinois after us yeah dude they bite
even when you have a bite suit they bite
so [ __ ] hard and they're pulling
right oh dude that's a 80-pound dog
belgian malinois they kind of look like
german shepherds but and they're a
skinny dog
keto german shepherd now take 150 pound
mountain lion
or a wolf or a [ __ ] bear that [ __ ]
thing came up
that thing will [ __ ] those things will
[ __ ] yeah look at the pictures
it's adorable if you're as big as
brennan but i probably haven't you can
absorb
that one trained like from the navy
seals yeah
yeah i don't think you would um i don't
think uh mountain lion would attack
somebody as big as you actually
there's only one way to find out and i
don't know yeah but a bear would better
be like yeah
there's like more meat do you see a
real wild moot like a [ __ ] male moose
10 foot from [ __ ] [ __ ] antlers
they're insane it's not hearing a peep
look at that [ __ ] thing
oh dude it was just it was the size of
the [ __ ] escalade word this thing
would have destroyed the [ __ ] car
you see that anaconda that swallowed
that dude what no yeah
like here or something like an indie or
something and it kind of swallowed a
dude like
that they're from south america this
thing this thing just swallowed a person
and it horrified me to this day i can't
what a [ __ ] way to get
the worst man connor yeah it was so i
mean
there's a picture uh
there's a picture is this rare no that's
it right oh this one yeah i was a python
dude
god that's a burnt off yeah
python didn't actually eat a drunk guy
in india if that's if that's not the
most horrifying thing you've ever seen i
i don't know what i don't know
it's just more horrifying you know
that's about i don't think that's real
though
there's one that there's a woman another
woman just like a month ago got eaten a
lot what
did you see the picture because they're
out they're out there they're out there
farming and then the water too oh dude
oh it was indonesia yep
now hold on yes i can't deliver what is
it that's what i know
no way oh dude indonesian woman 23
foot long python swallows indonesian
woman that scares you huh yeah i don't
even like to look you're all bunched up
about it i get it dude
all right it's off i guess no no no no
i'm just feeling it apparently i
wouldn't have a
mustache she looks very that was a man
yeah that looked like a man
that was a man it said indonesia said
woman but she had a mustache
you know go to some current events dude
some current events
so a retired nun who used to be the
principal
at a uh private school here in
california was recently arrested because
she
embezzled over 800 000 from the school
so she can gamble in vegas
yup she got audited and what i thought
was funny is that she
is also being investigated with another
nun that helped her
and the nun was asian and i feel like
because it's gambling and asians that
the asian nun
had everything to do with it just love
gambling love gambling yeah what is it
like the slots right
uh in vegas we love slots we love
roulette
yeah exactly i don't know what it is but
i think it has something to do with
chinese new year and how we like to
gamble to almost like test our luck
throughout the year
that when you go to vegas it's like on
steroids because i think the biggest
miami when i went to a hard rock cafe we
walked through the casino yeah [ __ ]
just asians galore specifically chinese
yes
smoking sipping one of my brother's best
friends he always got the ugliest white
people in the chinese kid just love them
they can't get enough can't get enough
of it just can't get enough just once it
goes goes
some people cannot stop i think i think
if you go to a casino and like i won two
grand once in one hand
and i was just like oh dude like that's
that was like i bought a car i was
like bet on sports is so much better i
know that's great
yeah having some action there's nothing
better i bet on [ __ ] fights it makes the
fight so much better
about how how are you how do you do
what's your overall record
i'm pretty good because because i work
with draftkings right so i got to look
into it and then give picks because
people are betting money on the pick so
i really look but as an ex-fighter now
like
i'm interested in this [ __ ] i don't i'm
sure you've got asked a million times
let me bore you with this [ __ ] but
when you're watching these guys like can
you
tell when you're watching them walk to
the before that you know when they're
doing the whole thing like this
when you see their eyes and you see you
could tell like oh this guy's either
nervous certain guys that i know
oh okay if i have a personal
relationship with him like god [ __ ] his
name he doesn't he doesn't look good he
doesn't look it doesn't look
okay so you could go especially i'm
really close so i'm like oh man he's
about to get [ __ ] up and if you don't
know him
it's a guess like like me yeah yep 100
percent what was the fight that you knew
that you
felt really confident where you weren't
that afraid roy nelson no no no
guarantee
i lost yeah and you were i was like i'm
going to steamroll both of them wasn't
nervous
you weren't nervous no didn't go my way
he's a dick
still though yeah that's god see that's
some [ __ ] like
listen i i had the pleasure of
performing madison square garden and
carnegie hall and [ __ ]
and like you know you bomb that stuff
but like i i think ufc i
i still say that's the most ballsy [ __ ]
to go in there knowing that you could
just
wake up going what happened yeah that's
the crazy thing is these [ __ ]
get knocked out and then you just feel
like they just
they look at the what happened yeah
yeah yeah i mean it's ballsy but at the
same time it's also stupid
it to me it takes more balls to get on
stay at my square garden
and you know like that's a different
animal getting put to sleep in front of
your kids though man
like when you i'm lucky because i yeah
like i don't know why fighters
i know like for inspiration but if i
have them rings i was like yeah
i would look at the vegas odds even on
myself
we don't have the kids at home yeah
sweetie don't don't let him watch tv
for a reason it's video game night
tonight
tell him daddy's going on vacation with
his boys
we're not watching the fight tonight
daddy's gonna get his ass whipped
and you know how like my son would
always say like if my son was like mad
at me he knows what to her and he'll be
like
well so maybe you're not that funny
could you imagine being a ufc fighter
and you don't get your kid a video game
he's like yeah well you got your ass
swept last week
what kind of game was it what did you
want little [ __ ]
it's so cut and dry man it's so that's
the thing it's so
that's the best way it's so cut and it's
so so is comedy though it's pretty black
and white yeah it is
it is either do well or you don't
understand and when you don't
see at least in fighting if i'm doing
bad it's it's gonna be a short night
you know then i'm back in the locker
room like all right i'll work on my
mistakes stand up there's sets where
you know if you have a full hour you're
20 into it and you know you're just
that's why i did teddy you're going
through the mud and you're like i'm up
here for 40 or
40 more minutes y'all like let's let's
try it teddy out i said the ring is
where
in any fighting arena you that's where
the truth comes out no matter what
you'll find out what the truth is and i
think stand-up's the same way seems like
you're up there
you're [ __ ] you either have it or you
don't i don't care who your agent is i
don't care what your talent is and
nothing drives me more nuts when it
comes back saying it's got that [ __ ]
crowd and then we go oh you think it's
the crowd you're talking about the
people that paid money
to laugh oh you think they're the
problem no exactly no no
there's only one common denominator do
you think it's the crowd last week too
no right it's not the crowd yeah yeah
greg fitzsimmons at best he's like
they're if you're not if they're there
to laugh
so if they're not laughing it's one
hundred percent
i agree with 100 yes
but it looks like a headlining set like
you have time to like
dig yourself out you could dig out of
like areas
you know it was interesting when i
didn't miss miss patch you know i did a
guess but
yeah it was a predominantly black crowd
what's weird is you know my my fans
i'll mess around with some of those the
gay stuff on my life would be easier if
i was gay
and the black crowd they didn't they do
not they did not play that game they did
not like the gay stuff
but then the other stuff they loved they
[ __ ] with yeah they loved
but the gay stuff they just did not
entertain everybody's got to do a black
crowd yeah
i came up doing when i was coming up and
no clubs would work i was just new
i would do i did the urban circuit i did
the black rooms contests and it was like
it was scary but that's different right
so i texted her because you know he
knows miss pat and he goes swing big
swing for the fence with a black crowd
he's like don't hold back
take big chances yeah i i would just had
to do it and just see
and like you know that was honest yeah
it's the most honest reactions you
you'll ever get
cause if they [ __ ] with you they [ __ ]
with you definitely happy yeah but if
they don't
they'll let you [ __ ] know yeah right
there on the spot i had one person go
preach
it's interactive it's a dope heckle
were you in new york when the boston
would do the sunday nights at the boston
challenge i did that a couple times that
was so sunday so the boston comedy club
was in new york it was in new york it
was called the boston comedy club was in
new york it was around the corner from
the comedy cellar yeah
and sunday night talent who's just so
hilarious
he was one of the like the new york
kings of comedy right yeah he would host
this thing
and crush and it was and all kind of
never outside
all comics were outside and you were
nervous you tried to get on and he put
me on one time and
you know it's just p it's just it's
really like it was felt like def jam but
like bring it be funny now
oh this was black knight yeah it was it
was a sunday night but like but all
comics would go but yeah and everybody
was like it was like a it was an
event and um and i did it and and
luckily
it went well but it was one of those
where you're thinking the whole drive
down you're like
this is this is going to be my drive
home real quick
for exactly 10 minutes and i was at the
new york comedy club on 24th street yeah
that's the first place i ever did in new
york city me too is it still got is it
still
yeah yeah uh the new owner emilio took
it over a few years ago
it's fantastic well i i uh it was an all
black crab
and i tried it i tried some animal [ __ ]
is there anything worse
i tried some animal [ __ ] about what's it
like to be reborn a legless
bird in the middle of
i heard this woman go wow
and it didn't get better from there yeah
they'll let you know i was like
i did one i had one really bad i
had good times i had good and i would
get into contests and do well but i had
one i'll never forget
i drove down to philly to the the laugh
house there's a black room on south
street
and uh i was yeah man i just got back
from kansas city and just one woman goes
why dude and the show was long
it was like and i want to write
she said why and i'm like not even 30
seconds in
and dude people just it was like two
hours
and the guy the guy before me goes i
think they called himself sugar bear
rested slowly passed away
but it was like all these comics and
they were like oh you'll go you did good
last time so you're going to co-host
which i mean you're going to co-headline
with sugar bear and he goes up and he's
supposed to do 20 and he does
and he goes boy now they're tired
and then they bring me up i just got
back from kansas and she just goes
why and people just slowly started to
like people
they just slowly they just started
walking like the midnight show was
about to start and people just started
slowly and i just stayed in it
that sugar bear uh yeah rest is so yeah
yeah i heard he passed away but so he it
was that
he goes on because before he goes on he
goes i think they're getting tired
they're getting tired or they're almost
tired then he gets off he goes
now they're tired and then i went up and
just
tried staying in the pocket and people
slowed the only time in my career people
just
were just tired just kind of like slowly
walking out
and then something was favorite and i
just [ __ ] i remember i got paid
and like as i got paid all right
like i didn't even want to say thanks or
bye he's trying to get to you
sometimes you'll find one hey you guys
keep that
you guys just keep it yeah
you know what you got to keep that top a
gesture a token there's a guy i won't
say his name but he's at the county
store and he he goes on very late and he
shouts
you know a lot and uh he
he got up he tried to get up and at a
club
and on the road and they said we'll
we'll yeah
we'll we'll headline you and he he's got
exactly 10 minutes
and it's funny if he's shouting at one
o'clock in the in the morning
at the comedy store and people the prime
hours
i know exactly and so he he he gets up
and he starts going
and people are just like now i mean
people are from this is in kansas and
they're like
they're like this no what's going on
it's not working in fact it was in it
was a [ __ ]
god it's a club in michigan doesn't
matter so he didn't
and they're so white in michigan and
everything else and he's he's just from
new york he's in here
and um he in the middle of the thing he
goes okay he literally
he goes for supposed to go for an hour
45 and
about 15 20 minutes in he goes thank you
very much and
runs away and he couldn't find him and
they couldn't find him and they found
him in a dunkin donuts [ __ ]
yeah he's sitting there like that
drinking coffee like that and
the owner of the club comes in and goes
hey man you're all right he goes i can't
have your headlines no problem no
problem
when a bomb hurts your soul it hurts
when you have one club you do it and
you're and people
yeah look at you as a novelty you gotta
and nobody
nobody no matter what level you're at
will ever not have that
you can be at the top of the mountain
and do a joke that gets
nothing and you just but i think what
happens is you get bulletproof where
you're like
you i think you have time you're like
yeah like you're like in your mind
you're going okay this is one where i
have to do this or that and different
tools come out and you get through that
one of the funniest [ __ ] you know you
guys know when you see somebody that you
know on stage and it's not going
dude i was i was at the stand and my
buddy is hosting and he's just hosting
the show
and he's doing all right and then he
does a joke that gets [ __ ]
nothing and then he just goes no but i
like you guys what's going on
i don't even know if anybody was in the
corner he pointed to you he just picked
the spot like yeah
[Applause]
like it was like him talking to himself
they didn't like it
i like the fact that he pointed out the
corner
what's going on back there it's so
related
there is absolutely nothing worse it
gets when it gets that quiet
you guys zombies
[Applause]
please throw me something hey what do
you what do you do huh you what do you
do for work
you guys are great you ready to keep
this show going
uh you guys know yeah when somebody's
not doing good you guys seem ready now
is it jailing out let's keep this energy
up your next headline
sir where are you from you look like a
gentleman oh
let's keep this energy up let us get you
starting out [ __ ] man oh [ __ ]
look at that point i've seen burr when
we're at the laugh factory
everyone's eating everybody's eating
dick
everybody then burp pops in and every
you know
season comes like good luck with this
bro you know
he's like goes up there and instead of
like just doing his bits he just
lights them up man like what the [ __ ]
wrong with you guys and just [ __ ]
yeah goes at them and then dude standing
applause
of course god and he's like are you guys
good and then walks out like jesus
i did show them recently but guy goes
yeah and he goes i don't need your
support i don't want your support
shut up i don't want your support
what else you got jen okay so an
eight-year-old boy
has a puppy who had parvo it's a really
bad disease for
younger dogs and it could kill them he
made he went viral online because he
basically sold his rare pokemon cards to
try to save his dog he was trying to
raise seven hundred dollars
him and his mom set up a gofundme and
when people saw him trying to sell
his collectible cards they actually
raised up to
five thousand dollars for him so his
puppy is great but pokemon found out
about this
and is sending him a bunch of new
replacement cards
so now these cards are going out for
like hundreds of thousands of dollars
like if you have
pokemon cards from like the 90s the
early 2000s you can sell them for a
bunch of money
so now on top of it he's just like he
has a great investment it's cool
kids kids with dog if you buy your kid a
dog
that's it and know that and know that
you're going to spend all the money
keeping everything alive you got to get
insurance for your dog because you're
not going to go home and say your kid
the guy there are certain things that a
dog has like if you if the dog's got
cancer and it's going to cost me five
thousand dollars you gotta do it
but you gotta do it for the kid well you
got a kid it said so my buddy
buys you know he buys two
italian mastiffs and they're like very
adults yeah kane corso right right right
yeah
so he gets these two amazing dogs now
now i yeah now i
i know my friend my friend travels a lot
i also know that 250 pound dogs
is not the best thing to have in los
angeles
for a lot of reasons i also know that he
doesn't have a lot of patience and he
again
travels a lot so i say to him i go
that's a bad idea because not i got it
so he gets he gets the dogs
and the dogs now he starts to realize
well they're puppies and they [ __ ]
everywhere and they pee everywhere and
there
and he starts to do he goes well they're
going to get bigger they're going to
turn their lions so he goes like this he
goes
he goes uh this is the dumbest idea in
the world you know the rails up the
train yeah i can't take the dogs i gotta
i yeah i gotta give him back guys all
right i get it you know
because i you know you get his money
back stuff that was a
that was dumb idea it was a dumb idea
man i don't know what i was thinking it
was [ __ ] crazy but
i travel six months of the year anyway
and it's impossible [ __ ] 150 pounds i
don't know
like one of those things you're like and
he goes up
he walks in he goes gotta get the dogs
gotta get the dogs guys coming to get
the dogs
his sons both his sons like this for the
dogs they go what
nigga's not happening we gotta go we
gotta give the dogs back
he goes like this the kid just looks at
me goes like this he gets looks and
death series he goes
that does not work for me my friend just
goes he goes all right
he's got the dogs for life now my kids
love dogs but their mom's a [ __ ]
hater man yeah she just doesn't like
dogs
yeah it's because she didn't grow up
with dogs right i feel like it's one of
those things
you also got a train i got a navy seal
for a dog yeah what do you what kind of
dog yeah i had a
malinois for a while i don't even know
what they look what i don't even know it
was the one
it's a german shepherd oh that's keto
yeah i want one of those i want like a
badass just don't worry
the problem is yeah the problem is
they're gonna bite somebody the problem
is you do something
for my son or yeah i can't have this and
they always look at like i wanted to get
one just to protect the house and like
people that's why i got it people were
like your family members are going to
come over and the thing's going to be
staring at them
like if it's not like immediate they
just like it's they're so on alert that
they're like
my only you the only commands i had were
in german it was so intense
yeah that's that's and they'd come over
have to learn german i'm like i don't
want to do all this man
and also when your kids are rough
housing your friend their kid's friends
kids
and their dogs there's like snaps and
stuff yeah
i don't want to buy a dog and then have
to learn another language
oh dude it was exhausting are [ __ ] my
buddy's a swat team he's a swat team
sergeant he's got his dog that takes
down dudes he's got about a hundred
bites on the street you know
he knows the taste of human flesh the
dog he's like my dog's a light switch
he's a
very friendly he's a light switch though
i can you know he's very trained
so his friend comes over and the dog the
dog is sitting there like this and the
dog goes
and my friend goes he goes he goes and
this is what my friend does he goes are
you afraid of dogs
and he goes well that one
don't because he can tell when you're
afraid just act normal oh yeah i don't
want to die i don't [ __ ]
ignore that malinois they're like make
sure you're running them a few miles a
day like you would say
oh because you have to like i became a
coach it's a working dog so that's a
certain type of german shepherd
uh it's in the same family it's a any
dog
those are really the military and those
are the dogs that the navy seal uses and
the police they need a job they're super
athletic they call them
sharp dogs they need a job dude so they
they bite
quickly yeah they want to work they're
very like eight miles a day within
something i don't want this that's why i
hate seeing like i saw this german i saw
somebody with like a siberian husky in
manhattan and i'm going
do that thing needs cold that wants to
work it wants to pull like it shouldn't
be in this yeah no
it's exhausting what else you got jen so
the french president went outside to
greet people
and he got slapped in the face by a
protester just because they don't like
him
i'd love to do this to newsome watch
this
first of all the way he slept and he was
like that was like
it was a very french slap oh okay
that protests that little sugar in their
tank yeah right
because it was too much for you that's
great
we'll get sugar in his tank oh yeah what
else you got uh so i think we should
probably do this
what there's a korean barbecue truck
that's in southern california
i think it's here in la too so truck
diaries oh no this is for like our team
because they only fit like four people i
think or even food truck drivers too
i like that though the guy that uh that
made this invented this stuff
though zion but the guy invented it he
was actually the winner of the food
truck
race whatever on one of those shows yeah
yeah yeah
anyway see more cooper did you see
oh you didn't see the the great the food
truck the great food truck
you guys know that like he was on
american idol on the [ __ ] food truck
you're like is it a sky on
yeah because yeah i never heard of that
no all right
we get it you don't know what it's
coming in oh hot dogs
what's his dad is [ __ ] a grown man in
the sky
on scion do you guys know the food truck
thing no i don't
no but check it out oh for food drug
diaries
for one day uh so you rent it for 500
bucks we can bring it here
in the parking lot that's not bad at all
you know you know
uh korean barber kitchen doesn't look
it's dj it's definitely decent
well thiessen is different right yeah
especially if you don't have to wait
three hours like we did last time yeah
yeah
that and now you know what it is like
ask me ask me how my career is
ask me if i if i'm if i'm working and
doing any film you're working hard
no you know what it is like right now
nothing's going on sometimes no words
you just go yeah
yeah no the other thing is how are you
doing busy
yeah yeah oh yeah you making money you
know what it is
right now and and you know too like in
our business you have those
friends who are your friends but they
want to get off the phone they want to
get off the phone first
to like you know you'll be like
all right man well listen i gotta i got
i got this meeting and it's like dude
we're
yeah yeah we have the same friends
yesterday when we were talking okay
we're going
i'm on a hike with tigers i'll call you
back we we pulled up to barnes and
nobody get out my tiger goes
dad did you did you lie to you
i go yeah he goes why are you because i
i didn't want to talk to him anymore
because the conversation was going
nowhere of course
so i just told him that so we could get
off the phone and
why don't you just tell them we're at
barnes noble i don't know these ask
questions
the height seemed easier and i know that
you don't so you lied to it i lied to me
you shouldn't be lying to your friends
but but i know it's a lie because i'm
like yeah
anyway yeah we can talk about how things
suck or things are good but it doesn't
oh who cares anyway see you later i lie
about how far i am
when i'm going with it yeah oh you're
that guy yeah like do one time my body's
like are you here yeah
i go do it i'm like i'm like then i'm
like 20 minutes i was in a i was
in a diner eating i was in a diner in
queens
because you're in your mind in my mind
i'm going i'm going to just hop on like
you think there's going to be
no no no no interruptions so
everything's perfect to get there and
you just lie and then he's like you're
you're not
it was [ __ ] there was a thing a
whole ice town that i'd be like late i
was
chronically late what happened i go it's
[ __ ] water main break
on but then i would take the same route
to get here
and i'd be dead serious lying to his
face oh yeah the water break
i'm stuck and i'm pissed i'm stuck i've
been waiting
so now i'm outraged at the water main
break that never happened
you do that stuff i got enough [ __ ]
this is the other thing i got in an
accident you did
i got my car's all messed up and that i
just holds up
i'm not a script whatever last one
last one um all right let me pick this
one then is this no not that
this we were tagging this look a bunch
it's just covered in
just look at this oh damn
god dawg that's a real place holy [ __ ]
dude
at first i was just a dirt i know
uh chappelle and i and david lucas
oklahoma city oklahoma brickstown comic
club this thursday
friday saturday yeah yeah great club did
you get the food did you eat the food
yeah great club yeah and they don't
spokane too
yeah but no that the seafood place
that's not like that's around the corner
yeah yeah you got to get the crab cakes
and believe it or not the cabbage and i
was like cabbage and they were like you
never had anything like that
butter really good with sauteed cabbage
with like butter
and the and the shrimp and the crab
cakes nuts oh we're in and it's right
near
where you're at oh hell yeah you know
the neighborhood i'll be at paul's
favorite club
albany uh june 18th and then
worst club he's ever been told funny
bone
how did he describe it uh june 18 the
19th and then
yeah you said if they if they hear this
he said never go back you're fine with
it
personally he said they never asked me i
think
what are you gonna do not having
personally personally i'm looking
forward to going to the capital of new
york state
in june and then i got philadelphia pa
helium comedy club june 25 26 27 get
your tickets
yeah this weekend this friday saturday
i'll be doing the uh
vulcan gas company austin texas yeah
friday one show saturday we'll see him
austin
uh salt lake city uh i will be well
actually that might be guys that might
be moving yeah but that might be moving
that's at the end of the month
uh i will be doing my first theater gig
guys in october
october 22nd at the wilbur tickets are
on sale for that i'm shooting my special
in september all dates are going to be
updated on paulversey.com check out the
version effect podcast
me and bill burst podcast anything
better check out my new youtube channel
and uh i appreciate having you man yeah
oh
grubhub is here y'all and what they want
to know is they
serve restaurants grubhub loves
restaurants from the food to the passion
and determination of people behind them
they know that restaurants reputations
matter
they'll be damned if their reputation
suffers because of them because good
food deserves good service
delivered fast fresh exactly how
restaurants intended to be
restaurants work hard to serve the
customers and grubhub works hard to
serve
them all right whether you're a
podcaster stand up comic or just an
overall badass you're working up an
appetite that's where grubhub got you
covered man
we got you covered you can order through
the grubhub app or online
let all the stress from eating finding
your next meal get out of the way with
grubhub all right the app
you just download the app grubhub we
serve restaurants
today grubhub is doing a little extra to
serve panera get a free delivery perk on
your first order from panera bread
of 15 or more that's grubhub's delivery
perk on your first order from there of
15 or more
what's up fire the kid listeners few
housekeeping notes
for uh i started a new thick boy
youtube channel i've dropped all three
vlogs from my
miami trip of the floyd mayweather logan
paul subscribe now we're gonna do a
special giveaway
when we get to 100 000 subscribers we
will pick three lucky
random subscribers i will fly you out to
la to work out with me
and my crew at zoo culture gym in
woodland hills
california so as soon as we hit a
hundred we'll randomly pick through you
you'll be notified and i will pay for
all your travel your lodging
and your workout it's gonna be dope so
head to the site right now it's thick
boy uh you gotta
uh search it right now um and you'll see
it on there post a bunch of videos bunch
of content so head to there right now
but this weekend i'm in oklahoma city
with chappelle lacey
david lucas it's been a beast of a show
that's june 10th through the 12th that's
this thursday friday saturday
brickstown convert club oklahoma city
then i get a little break your boy will
be in pittsburgh
pennsylvania pittsburgh improv july 22nd
through the 24th
get tickets right now f-a-t-k-z dot-com
man if you're out there and you're cbd
user or you don't know about cbd and you
want to try one you're like it's just so
complicated i got to go this side go to
this or maybe
you have your favorites and you're like
i usually always use this i wish there
was an easy way to get this done i got
something for you talking about direct
temp it's like the amazon of cbd
you can choose from dozens of products
from multiple brands the most popular
brands
probably the brands use them right now
and get everything shipped in one
convenient box
they have all the brands the major ones
orders are shipped
order shipped before 11am central time
ship out the same freaking day
all right orders are dropped off right
at your doorstep
uh direct temp members get free shipping
on every order you can also set up
subscription that's what i did
so for your favorite products you get
them automatically sent to your
uh house at your convenience when you
set it up all right they usually add a
free gift to every order so it's always
easy to try new products
uh they also have 24 7 customer service
they have 100
satisfaction guaranteed all you got to
do
for all your cbd needs of the best cbd
products in the world
go to freaking uh what is it direct
go to directhemp.com promo code is thick
thick with three c's t-h-i-c-c
for 10 off the entire damn site father
day is coming up
i know your dad's joints hurt give him
some cbd man
get him relaxed maybe he has anxiety cbd
helps with all that
go to directhemp.com promo code thick
for 10 off